Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast. Yeah.
Just checking in on. Yeah. I'm
just checking in on, you know,
you almost through the week so me and
get paid today. Some of you don't.
I don't it fucking works. But um, yeah,
I'm just here to check in on you
just fully the fucking half an hour.
I hope you guys enjoyed the very special
edition to the Monday morning podcast
that was put out yesterday
with, uh, the great,
the Great Jim Norton promoting his new
standup special that you can watch now on
Netflix. Mouthful of shame. And I've
heard nothing but great things about it.
I have yet to see it
because, uh, you know,
I only got so much fucking time now
with the little kiddo running around who
just get,
just keeps getting better every day.
Just keeps getting better every day.
I don't know what the fuck people
complain about, about having a kid.
It's fucking awesome. Oh,
it good. You're good to go.
As opposed to watch sitting
alone in your apartment.
All of free time in the fucking world.
Slowly drinking yourself to death.
Cause I'll tell you,
I've been up both sides of the fence,
like in this side a little better.
Not saying every once in a while,
every once in a while I don't have visit.
My old friends did my fucking 83
76 years level bar that I have.
I always throw it.
I always give a shout out to the 83 76
and because everybody talks about the 96
bowls and everybody talks
about the 27 Yankees.
What about the 1983 Philadelphia?
76 years.
I would love to throw
the 86 Celtics in there,
but the fucking Lakers choked against
the Houston Rockets. So I mean,
sort of a a,
you know when in the 80s it didn't mean
you didn't really feel like you won a
championship. Lsu beat the Celtics and
the Lakers. That's basically it. That's,
that's my, you know, no disrespect to Rau.
Fucking Samson.
No fucking disrespect.
Do Chemo Olijahwaun Lucy on the team yet
or are they a fucking treating all tree
rounds was Atlanta.
I don't remember.
They had very similar uniforms
in my memory bank. In fact,
I think they had the exact same colors,
just Houston Rockets was less busy.
More traditional like the Detroit Red
Wings, jersey, simple red and white,
Toronto, blue and white. It's it.
It's over. These are our colors.
Fuck you somebody.
Please explain to me how the Tampa Bay
fucking lightning also can wear blue and
white. I don't understand that. You know,
it's like the Pittsburgh penguins when
they came back white or black and gold.
It's like,
what the fuck?
Barden Nick told me that the original
fucking hockey team in Pittsburgh did wear
black and gold, but then yeah, but then
you folded and you left it on the table.
It's like when you don't
renew your fucking website,
somebody else who's going get it. Um,
I don't know what I'm talking about.
All I know is I have to plow through this
next fucking half an hour just to see
how you're doing. Whatever. Maybe I'm
going to catch you on the ride home.
You know, worst case scenario,
you got one fucking day left.
Use a sick day, take a three
day weekend. You know, you know,
I was actually thinking now is
this is the time of year where, uh,
the spring break,
I wonder what kids do nowadays.
It's gotta be a way where they can
get out of the view of the constant
surveillance of your parents.
Now,
you know what I mean?
Jesus Christ.
By the time my daughter
gets to that fucking age,
I'll probably be able to have a drone
hovering over her for her the entire
fucking existence.
I'll just shout down from the sky,
you know? [inaudible] don't go to
that party. Just freaking around.
She'd be looking up like dad,
oh,
so sick of my dad hovering over me in a
hoe and a fucking whatever the fuck it's
called. That will literally
be helicopter parenting.
No,
it's fucking drones.
I went to something recently and I guess
the gift bag was a drone. It's like,
why would you give people a six
it's not intrusive enough.
All this fucking technology that all these
fucking Weirdos, you know what I mean?
I want to know the first time a drone
is going to seriously give somebody's
brain damage because the operator was
trying to jerk off while they were trying
to operate it
is they'll hovering over
somebody's fucking house, you know,
trying to come down here, the bathroom,
this already perverts doing that
perverts fascinate me,
but the fascinating music,
why can't you just walk up and say hello?
They can't do it,
but then they have these needs, right. So
then they got to peek around the corner.
You know, speaking of
Pekin, peaky blinders,
what are my favorite fucking shows? It's
coming over the last five years. Um,
I was on a,
uh,
an airplane flying back from Austin,
from the south by southwest festival.
Uh,
which I can't tell you another time
when you would not want to be in Austin.
You know? I mean, it's great for films
and that type of Shit, but it's just like,
I don't know, man. I don't know
what happened to that city.
I've been going there for the last 20
years. It just gets more and more crowded.
It's like a bunch of sweaty
hippies with la level traffic.
That's what south by southwest is.
And I don't know what it is.
Every white person in
Austin during that week,
they all look like they play hacky sack.
You know,
I don't know if there's just
something about the, uh,
the disheveled on purpose colleged
age white kid that I know.
Even when I went to college,
I wasn't like that, you know,
fucking combed my hair when
I still had hair. Right.
I didn't try to fucking look
like I lived out on the street.
It was like a big guy thing back then
to try to look all fucking disheveled.
Like I could barely take care of myself,
but look at my college id.
Look at my crazy picture. Take
Dude, you did. All of the sudden,
this whole fucking thing is on purpose.
The end of the fucking day.
If your back's against the wall, you
can call your mom and dad. All right,
so fucking comb your hair and put it on
a clean shirt. All right. You can't, oh,
I'm sorry. What did I say?
All of that. Anyways, I, um,
this was my day.
I actually was flying out there at that
day to do the all things comedy podcast
and then fly right back.
So I, uh, I'm like,
this is great.
I've always wanted to go to the airport
and just have like nothing and just walk
in, you know, like Leonardo Dicaprio
in catch me if you came every,
just come fucking walking in
wearing this little fucking,
I know how to fly a plane outfit.
That's what the fuck I wanted to do,
minus that outfit. So I put
on sweatpants, you know,
and I would have a fucking tee shirt
jacket and I had my change of clothes and
toiletries in this backpack and
that was fucking it. All right.
Went in there like a Goddamn drifter and
I get all the way to the airport and I
realize I forgot my fucking wallet.
Right.
So I can't get on the fucking plane
cause I don't have any form of
identification. I don't have my
college id man from back in the day.
And, um, what did I have?
Um,
I ended up having to go.
Yeah,
I didn't know what to do. I was
like, I'm going to miss this fucking,
and I'm actually thinking now that my dad
actually did grow my hair out a little
bit in college,
but I still dress respectfully.
Maybe I was a hybrid. I can't fucking
remember. It was so fucking long ago.
Anyways,
so I fucking get to the airport.
I don't have my God damn id and I don't
know what the fuck to do and I have to
make this,
this podcast cause his advertisers
and all that type of shit.
You can't say this is the lineup.
This is the projected amount of
people that are going to listen.
It's a business and then not show up
and take the fucking money. So, uh,
I didn't know what to
do. So I ended up, uh,
the first time ever I flew private
and blue a fucking ton of cash.
So I'm going to be playing a bunch of
casinos coming up to make up for the money
that I,
uh,
that I spent on that I flew out of
Van Nuys like a fucking rock star,
lit up my card, literally glowing in
my pocket. I had to fucking drive home,
get my wallet, fly out, you know,
drive out there and then sit there and
then talk to these fucking savages.
Just being like, oh, you need
a plane right now. Ah, really?
That'll be 1 million bucks.
And I'm like,
fuck you wind up calling somebody else.
And they're like,
it'll be a half a million.
I'm like, fuck you.
And all you do is you just keep calling
people and after awhile you just start
numbers and um,
I got it.
I got a way the fuck down for
whatever they first quoted me.
I have that got it down to half that,
but it's still cost to
Fuckin zillion bucks. So a,
I get on the plane talking to the
pilots to like right fucking there was a
smaller plane, like when I
went to take a Piss, I'm like,
do you guys have a bathroom here?
They're like, yeah, they do.
And they had to move to snacks and then
they closed it a little door and I'm
taking a piss right on the
other side of the fucking door.
And like you can't stand up in the plane.
So I am Standup,
but I'm acting like I have osteoporosis
and I'm trying to take a fucking piss.
And this does an angle you have to be
at so you don't piss on your own fucking
sweatpants.
But eventually the velocity of the urine
coming out of your Dick is going to
slow down and it's going to
come towards your clothes.
So then he got to make a decision. What
am I going? How am I going to do this?
How far down am I going to pull my pants?
What the fuck's going on?
Like that weird kid. Remember that weird
kid when you were in elementary school,
you went in to take a piss and the kid
had his pants all the way down around his
ankles. It's like, why didn't
you just fucking unzip you fly,
you know what's going on here?
And then the whole time I'm just
thinking like, how is this better?
They'd fly in on a commercial airline.
I don't get it. You know, if you,
you're flying business of first,
if you bump yourself up, uh, the,
I am one and done on that shit.
I just think it's the,
it's a colossal fucking waste of money.
And I have the glowing fucking
credit card right now to prove it.
And um,
there's just no money in it.
The fucking people who rent the
plains of barely making any money,
the pilots don't make any money.
All the pilots,
one eventually fly for commercial,
a commercial airline, right? I mean,
there's still flying commercial private,
but they want to fly for like, you know,
one of the major airlines
is what I'm trying to say.
So one of the pilots came back and
he's talking to me. He goes, yeah,
we got some beers here. And I'm
like, I'm on the wagon. But I'm like,
well what the fuck? I spent all
this money. I got to have a beer.
So I drank a cores light like the
white trash cunt that I am. And um,
he's sitting there talking to me and uh,
I'm all fascinated with the hall,
the aviation aspects of it.
And I'm sitting there looking at the guy
and he had a tear in his slacks, right?
It, his knee. Like there was a
like a, like a vertical slice.
Like he was in a knife fight and
just so many sliced it a little bit.
And I was just going like,
there's no fucking money in this.
What this guy's doing right now define
the law of gravity getting me from Los
Angeles to Austin. He doesn't
get lost. He knows where to go.
He knows what altitude to fly out.
We had a nice fucking landing
when my life is literally in this guy's
hand and they don't pay this guy enough
money that he can fly this fucking jet
without a pair of pants that have fucking
ripped. You know, maybe that's why
all those kids fucking annoyed me.
You notice I didn't fit,
you know when I was in Austin,
cause I'm seeing a guy who
actually really is struggling.
It's line of fucking jet and he has
fucking ripped slacks. Who knows?
Maybe you just had a rough night. Hey had
a rough one. Maybe you just passed out.
I don't fucking know. Anyways,
um, I remember when I was in,
in college and uh, yeah, like I, I d
I was never that fucking rebel guy.
I remember walking by this chick one time
and I just had like mainstream clothes
on.
I had like a polo shirt and regular shit.
I remember I walked by and she
just goes, Ooh, hot labels.
Okay.
I just want to be like,
you fucking golf con you look like
every other fucking golf caught here.
Do you guys all,
I don't know what fucking every black,
everything painted black store.
You fucking walking.
You all have the same fucking makeup.
You all have the same fucking lipstick.
Yeah. It just, you know, cause
there's no golf food court.
You feel like you're out of year out
of the reach of the corporations.
I'll never forget that. Ooh, hot labels.
And I kind of liked her too, cause a lot
of those got chicks with cute, you know,
if you could get past the fucking,
you know, now a days I would actually,
I would totally steer clear of them
knowing what I know. It's like, Oh God,
let me, I would have one question. Do
you or do you not hate your parents?
You do and see Ya.
I'm not fucking going through that shit.
Those fucking long talks about everything
that they did to you. You know, Eh,
you know what my parents did shit to,
you know,
and I'm a parent now and I'm
going to do shit. You know?
That doesn't mean you got to fucking walk
around dressed like you were in awake.
Okay.
That'd be why you dressed like that
cause you got bullied. Now look at you.
Now you're just bringing
this shit onto yourself.
What are you waiting for bullies to
become enlightened and be like, oh,
I guess people have the right to be
different. It's not going to happen.
So at the very least,
if you're going to walk around like that,
it at least at some point
take the makeup off,
going to a Dojo and learn some fucking
MMA shit so you can protect yourself.
So I guess in the end of the day,
I'm not really attack and golf people.
I'm really saying, hello, fuck
her. She's still judged me.
Right? Ooh, hot labels.
I was sipping on those things where you
walk and he kind of stopped for half a
second and then you is, is it worth it?
It's not worth it. And I just kept going.
I forget what her fucking name was.
It was either Natasha a brook,
which was always a fucking hot
girl name when I was growing up.
Yeah,
I never really saw a brook that wasn't
good looking. Natasha's were good looking.
Debbie's Debbie's. We'll fun. Debbie's,
we'll find girl weird like do you
give you give a fucking person a name,
you know what I mean? It was like
bill, you know, just blending in.
Bill lost in the crowd.
Yeah.
Oh, mainstream bill with this corporate
clothes. Just walking down the street.
I did have the red afro for a while
when I got into fucking radio.
I fucking grew it out a little bit and uh,
I think I had the beard all that's when
I got into drums and I was trying to be
in a band and that's what I was trying
to grow my hair out and it just went out.
Which would have been cool in the sixties
or seventies I would have looked like
Bernie for Brent to 22 but
by the 80s it wasn't cool.
You had to have the law on fucking hand.
Just never worked for me.
The comedy gods, they just pulled
me in. It's like, listen bill,
you'll look like a douche
no matter what you do. Okay.
You're not a good looking guy. You
look like a fucking freak. Okay.
The only hope for you
is to stand on stage.
And make fun of yourself and make a
little bit of money. Why don't you,
why don't you cash in on your Orange Afro?
You know,
I think that that's what was going on.
And eventually I, I, that's what I did.
That is exactly what I did.
And then when I was making enough money
in the business, uh, the comedy, God said,
okay, you don't need your orange afro
anymore. And they took it from me. Um,
I don't know what the fuck
I'm talking about. Oh,
I know what I wanted to
bring up two weeks in a row.
I'm going to give you a great movie.
I told you I saw Jordan peals get out,
which is so fucking such you a
great movie. And so, you know,
different from everything
else that's out there.
I'm actually going to win
joy watching Hollywood now.
Try to rip that movie off.
It's like get out meets people who
don't know how to make a get out.
I think they're going to
do the Latino version. Um,
however you say get out in a Latino,
you know,
Serato Vamanos I don't
what the fuck you say?
I'm starting to remember sesame street
and we had to enter and exit ibn though
sat out. Oh, that was close. I don't
fucking room. I don't know. You know,
whatever this is.
Some fucking white guy will get a resent
a stone and he'll figure out how to say
it. Not Try to rip off that
movie. That was a great movie.
And this week, um, I was on the
plane ride back from Austin.
Wait a minute,
typing in my password and I saw the guy
from peaky blinders killing and Murphy
don't know nothing about no robbery.
Oh fuck you with the fucking password.
Hang on second.
God dammit.
There we go. It's called, I don't,
I hope I say this right. It's um,
anthropoid a n t h r o p. O, I. D.
And it's based on,
they say the extraordinary true
story of operation anthropoid uh,
the World War Two mission to attempt
to assassinate ss General Reinhard
Heydrich. Um, and what I love is it,
it's a story I never heard.
You know,
granted I don't fucking read and it
takes place in a checklist of Aki and
Prague. And I had no idea. I
knew that Germany, you know,
they lost I guess
Austria in World War One.
And then, uh, you know, a star came back
and he's just like on TV should have that.
And then he just took fucking Austria
and nobody in Europe did anything.
And everyone's just like, wow,
well maybe that's,
maybe they'll just be happy with that
and we won't get involved in this fucking
world war thing again. And then I
thought he went immediately to Poland,
but evidently, oh, fucking evil.
Charlie Chaplin himself went to a
checklist of Archaea I had no idea and uh,
made me want to read up
on the subject and um,
it's a fucking amazing,
amazing movie. And a,
it's one of those movies where,
uh, what they're talking about,
the behavior was so heroic
as you're watching it,
you're actually sort of squirm and going,
like,
how would I react? What I would
hope that I would be one of these,
okay,
you know, the good guys here as opposed
to the person just trying to blend in.
Well,
the not coming after me and I just sort
of do whatever the fuck they see now
choose like self preservation, which
I gotta be honest with you. Like,
I would never fault a parent for doing
that because once you get your kid like
you just like so focused on your fucking
kid, you just like, fuck all adults,
you know, not fuck all
adults. It's just like, well,
I'm not creating a situation where
they, I gotta I, I got a kid, you know?
Okay,
but you'd like to think like,
you know what?
Fuck that I'm going to teach my kid how
to shoot a fucking Uzi and let's go Nazi
hunting. You know, you'd like to
think that you were that person
as opposed to sitting there quietly
eating your soggy corn flakes.
You know,
this is the thing about being a
coward is if nobody else knows,
you'll forgive yourself.
You know,
it's other people knowing it. Just staring
at your shoes for the, the, you know,
waiting for the people that know what
a coward you were during that time.
Eventually die or you die or whatever.
But it's a fucking unbelievable
fucking movie. Absolutely loved it.
And um, directed by Sean
Ellis. I liked this.
I like giving shout outs cause not a
lot of people go to movies anymore.
Shadow some of these fucking
talented people here.
And it starts Jamie Dornan,
killy and Murphy.
I hope I said that right.
It's spelled c I. L. L. I. A. N. A. Okay,
come on. You got to have a couple of
broads in here with some loving inches,
right? Oh, I'm never going say
this. Sarah Amro savage Strava.
Hannah fried joke,
joke for this crisis is like trying
to name a fucking hockey player now.
Hannah F R E J K O v.
A with a fucking hatchet
mark right above it.
Okay.
I don't know what it was. Uh, it
was amazing. Great fucking movie.
Check it out if you get a
chance. If you're on American
Airlines, it's played. Um,
I don't know if they get extra money if
they do it that way. I know. All right.
Anyways, let's read a little bit
of advertising here for this week.
What do we got here? Oh, but oh
doot doot me undies, Mija, Andy,
shoot a couple of fucking
Nazis. But Dude, dude, dude,
me undies me undies play in
when you're wearing Yahtzee,
a fucking Ryan fuck off you
fucking balls will feel real nice.
Shavia ahead.
If you got lice.
I like me undies on my Tate's.
It makes me have really good dreams.
Oh yeah.
Unlike the generic ones when you're
wearing Hanes, right? Ooh. Hot labels.
All right,
me undies.
Okay.
Oh man, that one's stuck with, isn't it
amazing the things that stick with you?
That was almost 30 fucking years ago
and I still remember it like it was
yesterday. Ooh. Hot labels. You know,
if I had a time machine, like I wouldn't
go back and try and stop Hitler.
I'd go back to that moment in my life
so I could turn around and be like,
and that'll be, that'll
be it. That'll be it.
And I get right back in and I would leave
anyways.
So Mandy's elevate your underwear game,
your underwear gang yo to the
next level with me on these me,
you've perfected your wardrobe.
Hey, but what about the stuff?
Not everybody gets to see, man.
If you've been settling for store,
bought underwear,
five packs,
if you've been settling to go into the
fucking mall and buying a pack of five
pairs of underwear, that some fucking
kid at to so together in El Salvador,
if you're sick of going
through that difficult thing,
I have something that will
change your life for the better,
and that is fucking me on these.
What's the first thing you put on
in the last thing you take off?
What does it do? Your underwear, right?
Unless you leave your hat on your
fucking Weirdo, it's your underwear.
Make your most important piece of clothing
the best it can be with me undies.
When's the last time you were completely
naked and you just had on a hat?
You know if there's anybody in the room,
they're fucking laughing, right? Key.
You cannot be completely naked and
just have on a hat and not do a dance.
It's impossible.
Especially if your guide,
then you got your junks fucking
shaking around. It's tremendous.
It's a great show actually. What is
beyond these? Oh, just seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered
right to your door beyond.
These are designed in
Los Angeles or Louisiana.
They don't really say la and
made from sustainable sources.
Micro Modal, modal of fabric,
three times softer than cotton.
Beyond these softer than
soft luxury undies coming in.
An ever changing selection of classic
colors. What is classic call is,
this is probably your basic, you know,
Crayon set when you were a little kid.
What's your favorite color? Whoa.
All right. Blow red, white, black,
brown, yellow, green.
That's it. That's it.
Like the original members
had guns and roses.
Then all of a sudden you get burnt Sienna.
You know when Matt Sorum comes in and
you get a little fucking a, I dunno,
some other fucking car off white. When
you get a, what does that Guy Dizzy?
Fucking something rather. Anyways,
bold shapes. Adventurist patterns.
So you can tailor your undies to your
own personal style. And guess what?
Guess what? You can save time and money
each month with a monthly subscription.
How much do you shit your pants
that you need underwear every month.
And if you're not ready
for a subscription, that's
okay. You can still save.
That's because me undies is
offering you 20% off the first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr
and get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it.
It'll put you in a good mood,
man. New Underwear and new socks.
You know that's like a
body off restoration.
You know you're not just putting a
coat of paint on this piece of shit.
The new pair of slacks, he going right
down to heal bowls. Once again, that's me.
undies.com/burr me undies.com/per a
better day for your taint frame bridge.
Everybody. Do you guys have a bunch
of photos laying around? We'll do you.
You got to arc.
It's rolled up in your closet.
Just waiting for you to put it in
a nice frame to hang on the walls,
but you know what to fucking deal
with that shit when it be great.
If there was just something,
you know you called Frey,
bridge.com you can send them all that
shit and then it would come back to your
house. Frank, you can put it up on your
walls and pretend you're interesting when,
that'd be great. Well, you can
do that with frame bridge.com.
Do you take a thousand photos that
never get put on a single frame?
Now you can get those great memories
off your camera on your wall with frame
bridge.com. Why frame
bridge? You might ask. Well,
prices start at just 39 bucks
and or up to 70% less than triff.
Traditional framing stores. Go to frame
which Dotcom you choose your frame from,
their curated collection.
Upload your art,
preview it before you buy can upload yard.
It's stupid bast at no worries.
You can mail it in for free.
You're framed piece of art at your
home. Um, arrives at your home,
ready to hang, get your
personal experience using
frame, bridge.com the site,
the ease of order, how your piece turned
out and how easy and affordable it was.
I know I read that wrong anyways,
I love frame bridge. Evidently.
I know you will too.
It's so easy to use.
I just delivered that like walking.
It's so easy to use. Uh, so much,
so much more affordable than
traditional frames stores. Right now.
Frame bridge.com has a special offer
just for my listeners and wherever else
they advertise with 50% off your first
order and free shipping when you use my
code burr. So get uh, get started
framing your art or picture.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
find your favorite frame
from the curated collection.
Upload Your Art or Male,
upload your art or mail it in for free.
Preview your art in your custom frame.
Enter my code burr checkout to get
15% off and free shipping. Don't wait.
This offer expires this week,
so go to [inaudible] dot com
use my code bur bur to save.
And lastly,
but not leastly.
Yeah.
Do you like to booze? Huh?
Do you like to get fucked up?
But you don't want to get pulled
over for drinking and driving?
Wouldn't be great if there was a
service that was like a taxi service,
but it wasn't,
it was just some person in a car.
While I introduce you to lift l,
Y,
f t cause she can never
spell it the correct way in
the modern air in the modern
era. Right? It's gotta be, it's
gotta be funky. Get people over this,
not l I f t man, that's the
squares. This is l. Y. F. T.
Like why would you drive
when you're drinking? Um, you
know, you know about Lyft,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
It's the APP that gets you a
ride in minutes on demand 24,
seven for less than the cost of a cab.
Uh, please include the following points.
By the way,
that fucking commercial,
I think it's full lift that they do on
TV where the people are robbing the bank
and they're freaking out. And then this
at one kid just sitting there going like,
oh, the guy's name Tim, that's a great
name. And he's totally fucking relax.
Don't that fucking actor in that is,
is should immediately be putting movies.
That's my own personal opinion.
Okay.
I thought it was very unique.
There's all,
I'm saying it's a great commercial retro
or all the way around. Two thumbs up.
Anyways, please include the following
points during your read. Okay.
If you've tried Lyft,
you know what I mean? Uh,
with Lyft you just download
the APP request to driver
and they show up in three
and a half minutes. On
average. That's really fast.
Everybody knows how this fucking works.
Every Lyft driver is fully vetted through
that 10 point safety standard one.
Have you ever fucked a kid? Okay,
good. We move to the second round to,
have you ever had a drone crash into your
neighbor because you were jerking off
watching them take a
shower? No. Okay. Three.
Yeah. Have you ever been
sympathetic to the Communist Party?
Whatever the fuck they say up to that
it kind of goes off the rails. You know,
once you haven't fucked a kid, you
know, you haven't killed anybody,
then it's kind of like, Eh, you
know, uh, you like to boost plan,
know, but how much do
you like to boost? Um,
10 point a standard including criminal
and DMV background checks, you know,
you'll get around quickly and safety
lift drivers are rated after every ride.
So only the best stick around. This is
like bill Belichick do your fucking job.
You don't have to worry about getting
into a filthy car with some creepy dude
with Lyft. You can tip in the APP, which
obviously leads to happier drivers.
So right now,
Lyft is offering our
listeners a special deal.
They get three free fucking rides,
dude,
up to $10 each.
That's up to a $30 value if he can't do
basic math when you enter the Promo Code
Bill Burr B I, l,L , B U R R,
all in capital letters to
make me feel important.
Just download the free Lyft app today
and enter the Promo Code Bill Burr,
no space,
all capitals.
You will respect me and
the payment section, uh,
you'll start with three free rides,
up to $10 each.
That's up to a $30 value.
If you have an,
if you do not have the ability to do that.
Basic Math,
10 times three is 30 a.
That's Promo Code Bill Bird,
no spaces. All capital letters,
enter Promo Code Belper,
no space. All capital letters.
Okay. He put my name in.
You put my name in fucking lights
on that goddamn website. All right.
Going up to then there's may half hour
just like that. Just like that. Oh,
wouldn't it be nice if you would shut
up. I'm going to in a minute. Um,
what do I have on the thing? Uh,
oh, I have a benefit benefit. Um,
on March 25th and I am for
M ms and it's here in la.
I for some reason don't have
the information in front of me.
I don't fucking know womb.
I'm co hosting it with Craig Gas.
It's rock against ms I believe is
going to be a bunch of musicians there.
Steven Adler, again, fucking Gilby Clarke,
uh, Rudy Sasso, Michael, Devin.
All of these fucking rock
stars are going to be there.
We're going to raise a bunch of money to
help try and find a cure for this bed.
Horrific disease as opposed to
what? Bill? A wonderful disease.
What about the disease of laughter?
I don't think we ever want to
cure that to me. I'm sorry.
I'm going to be in San Jose this week.
Everybody, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
I'm doing two shows a night.
I got my new shit going on.
I was supposed to do the
goddamn comedy jam, but I'm,
my fucking shoulder is messed up.
And uh,
I've been driving my old truck to
that's three on the tree and that's the
shoulder that's fucked up.
But I actually was bothering
me just to shift on the column.
That's how fucking old I am.
Like someday I might have to sell that
truck because it hurts my shoulder to
just shift. It only has
three gears. I know.
It's fucking pathetic. I've been fallen
off on the Bruins and the Celtics,
I know the Bruins scored a bunch of goals.
I know we beat the bulls the
other day, but then the, uh,
the Bruins scored like six goals,
four goals in the third period.
I watched the first period of both the,
uh,
the Vancouver and the Calgary game.
And that was always my,
my fantasy when I was young as a fan,
when I went on the road, you know,
I was just like, I would love to do
that fucking western Canada road trip.
You know, back then it was
Calgary, Edmonton, Vancouver,
and maybe played Winnipeg too.
And then the last end they went down
and they played the La Kings in La.
Kings would just sit in a way out
in the west with nobody narrow.
Like the closest fucking
team I think was Vancouver.
And then the next closest would probably
be, would have been the St Louis Blues,
maybe Chicago Blackhawks, I would
guess Saint Louis. They would just,
there was no fucking team west of
St Louis other than the La Kings.
So no wonder the ants such tar time took
him so long to win a fucking cop along.
They had to fly. Vancouver's never
fucking one. One Calgary one once,
right.
In 89,
they'd be fucking Patrick Wa
and the Montreal Canadians. Uh,
I want to say Pat Burns was coaching
that team. I can't remember. Edmonton.
Edmonton fucking lit it up.
So anyways,
let me see if they'd beat
Calgary last night. Boston Bray,
we go bro. When here we go. Boston
Bruins, they're flying around the ice.
I Sub Pasta Knox 29th goal.
Okay.
He's really fill up, fill in the
uh, Tyler Sagan void. When you say,
you know,
since Tyler Sagan left eye Marshawn became
a legitimate superstar and now pasta
knock is on his way. So I guess
we're doing all right. You know,
we survived it and I actually think
Tyler's Sagan [inaudible] shown us
congratulating ourselves. I think we
want Bruins extinguish the flames.
You get it. You get it.
It's like they're on fire.
David Back has returned from a collision
into the boards. Yeah, that was scary.
That looked like me and pick up hockey.
Um,
oh for fuck sakes.
Where did the story go?
Gailey's score the game winner
as a Bruins down the flames,
five to two in Calgary on Wednesday night,
we scored six goals and Vancouver
five 11 goals and to fucking games.
You know, all my fucking bitch
moaning and complaining. Um,
Marshawn humbled by emerging
status as a lead score. Yeah,
that's absolutely right.
What about pasta?
Marshawn had a hat trick in Vancouver
and I fucking missed it too.
All of a sudden we're scoring goals and
I was sitting there whining st do not
get rid of Clo Julian and it's been a,
it's totally worked out.
It's worked out for us.
It's worked out for him.
It's worked out for the Canadian
so it's all good. And um,
we're flying around the ice with the
new coach Cassidy. That's fucking great.
That's fucking great. I love it. I love,
it's good to see Douggie Hamilton to
seem to be doing all right out there and
camp and Calgary.
I never had to have a fucking problem
with experts even if they decided to try
to take more money. I don't give a
fuck. She will career have a good time.
Good to see. It's still
in the league. You know,
I know you're out there in the saddle
dome that doesn't get a lot of love down
here in the lower 48, as they
say in Alaska. Um, anyways,
that's the podcast I got to get on
with my fucking day here. Oh my God.
My wife said the fucking greatest thing
to me ever to fucking motivate me to
work out.
I was sitting there looking in the mirror
in the bathroom and I just fat shamed
myself every fucking night.
That's how I stay in shape.
Right. And I just, you know,
I went off the rails and I ate steak
and shake twice and ate Mcdonald's twice
and had burger king.
This month has been like fast food.
When I'd been on the road, I don't know
what's been going on with me. Right.
So I was looking at the
results of that diet
and I was just looking in the mirror
and I called myself a tub of fuck,
which I've never said in my life.
I was just like, you fucking
soft mushy tub of fuck.
And then neo was in the other room
going like, what's going on with you?
I don't know. Look at me. I'm fucking, I'm
a mess. She goes, you, Oh look dad bad.
I go, Yay. Do Look at me. I got a
fucking dad bod now and she goes, no,
you don't. I go, nick, you're not
helping me. You know I need honesty here.
And then she just goes,
all right,
you're not his tone as you once were.
And I just went, fuck yeah. She goes,
I'm sorry you said that. I said, no,
you're doing me a favor. So
that's it. Now I've been on it.
I'd been on it like the Joe Rogan company.
I've been foreclosed on it. All right.
OATMEAL, fucking poached egg
in the morning. By the way,
when you make you poached eggs,
if you want to have them like they
do in the restaurant, you know it's,
it's spooning with itself.
This is such as simple trick.
I didn't even know it for all these years.
Just swirl the water.
I know I've said this before,
but maybe you missed the podcast.
Just swirled the water. Get a
little whirlpool going. Okay.
And then you crack the egg,
you drop it right down the center
and it's like a figure skater.
You know when they do the fucking spinning
around, it just, it brings its arms in.
And then you go,
you take it out with a slotted spoon,
you put it on a fucking English muffin.
Unless you like me.
If you're a tub of fuck and
you're trying to lose weight,
there's no English muffin.
It's just sitting in naked and afraid.
That is the dumbest fucking show.
Do you know there's no price?
These people go out there and get like
fucking Lyme disease got ants crawling
around their balls and up into
their fucking private parts. I mean,
I just don't understand why you would
do that. Cavemen were not naked.
They were definitely afraid,
but they fucking killed something
and they covered up their junk.
I actually saw this guy naked in
a fucking tree with a hatchet.
This is just the commercial
because I refuse to watch that.
I don't watch that show.
You know,
black people will watch shit that
because it's a bad representation of
themselves.
That's what that show is for white people.
There's very few shows out there that
bring white people down, you know,
because white people are running shit.
So we always make ourselves the
fucking heroes. I'm naked and afraid.
That's not a good show for white people.
That is every stereotype of a fucking
white person. Just like, you know,
I think my life is just too fucking easy.
I got to make it difficult or do,
I took all my clothes off, went into the
fucking juggled sof. I could survive.
Okay.
Naked and afraid. So this fucking guy
and just in the commercial for it,
he's up in a tree and he's fucking
hack and at this branch in this tree,
he's sitting in and then the whole fucking
branch collapses and it's just like,
that reminds me of some
shit from like bugs bunny.
Okay.
Where the somebody be sitting on a branch
in this sign off and it's sitting on
the wrong side of it and then they
fall off or the whole tree falls down.
I literally watched this
guy do with live action.
A real person did that to himself. He
was, but he was hacking on the right side,
but still,
I don't know what happened.
The whole thing fucking falls
and now he's falling in.
Yeah.
To like a bunch of like branches
sticking all like just completely naked.
You know,
I never cut my balls my entire life.
I never got a scratch on my balls.
Nothing.
Cause they were covered up.
I had on a pair of pants
claims a fucking tree naked.
MMM.
Anyways,
I don't know why I'm talking about this.
I don't know why I had this level of
passion for a fucking show. I don't,
I don't even watch, uh, that's the, uh,
day I checked in on you. Okay. You guys,
you guys have,
you guys have yourself a great fucking
weekend or I get cards and I will, uh,
I'll talk to you on Monday. All right,
that's it. Go fuck yourselves. And uh,
God bless the United States of America.
Okay,
quick
slack.
Hey, what's going on? It's still bird. It
is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 16th, 2009. Um,
I didn't know what this is the
year of anybody. Asian listening.
What is it the year of? Is it
the year of the Monkey? Um,
I am in San Francisco right now and uh,
I can't believe it.
It's drizzling out and it's cold
and it's miserable. It's just,
I just blew my mind because every time
I come to San Francisco, the weather,
it's just, it's just, you know, it just
puts a smile on your face, you know,
it's just one of those,
you know,
which I don't know when the fuck they
ever filmed that rice a Roni commercial,
but it must've been like the one sunny
day in the last 10 fucking years out here.
Cause this is the 12th time
I've come to this city.
I just pulled that number out of the air.
But whatever.
What a suck every time.
I mean it's like physically impossible.
Um,
and I mentioned I have a touch of a cold.
I usually get sick when I come here.
Dave is actually a little bit sick before
I got here. How did you get sick belt?
Well, I'll tell you, I went to a
Joshua tree national park and uh,
evidently I didn't dress properly as I
hiked my way out to somebody's goldmine.
Literally, um, Joshua
Tree, definitely, uh,
definitely a good time. Although I made
a real, I made a big time fool of myself.
I showed up and uh,
I asked the ranger,
I swear to God he was a ranger,
but he's working in the gift shop,
so I forget he sucks at being arranger,
you know what I mean?
Probably accidentally started a fire
rather than put in one out in the,
in the park. So, uh, I asked
the ranger, I, you know,
it's called Joshua tree.
So in my mind, you know,
there's this big beautiful park and this
is one fucking Joshua tree and that's
what everybody comes up to. And you
know, like that, what's that wallet?
All those Jewish people go up and pray to?
I thought it was something like that,
some sort of Mecca. Right?
So I say, yeah, you got,
it gives me the map of the whole,
the whole park.
I'm actually getting embarrassed
telling the story. I actually said,
so where exactly is the Joshua Tree?
Is it like,
is it like one tree?
Is it like a group of like five trees?
And the guy's looking at me and
then just the way he looked at me,
I just realized,
I just said probably the dumbest fucking
thing I could possibly say within them
park. And evidently this is what
I learned it in defense of myself.
I am from the east coast.
Every gift,
Bentley a Joshua tree is just the type
of tree and I had probably driven by like
200 of them on the way up to
fucking talking to this ranger.
There was probably three
of them in the parking lot.
Basically there for you people
on the east coast who ever,
if you ever go out there, there is no
Joshua tree. It's just a type of tree.
And if you go to Joshua tree and you say,
so where is the Joshua
tree that would like be,
that'd be like going to New Jersey
and going, um, where is the pine tree?
The pine tree that,
you know,
the special one and uh,
you know, uh, just, yeah,
I don't know. I, you know,
I just got the directions.
I just found out how to fucking get there.
I had no information about it.
But you know, in defense of me,
they should name the park. Uh,
Joshua trees, plural, not Joshua tree.
It confuses people.
And then they ask silly questions and
then they feel stupid and then they tell
us, we tell the story on their podcast
and they get slightly embarrassed. Uh,
so anyways, that was my
week. Oh, you know something.
I went to the San Jose sharks game on
Saturday night on my way up here to do my
one, my two shows here up in San
Francisco, saw the shark's speed, uh,
the kings in a shootout and
at the game I saw a 50 to 50,
I'd say about 55,
58 year old Guy Punch a 27
year old kid right in the face.
And it was fucking hilarious. Um,
there was this kid he had on this uh,
Detroit Redwings Jersey
A's hat on backwards,
you know that right out of the gate he's
just standing up screaming shit and he
was cheering on the sharks. So
Evan, I don't know what happened.
I think cause he kept
standing up. Anyways, this,
this chick who's also like 55, 58,
she's got this awful for coat on,
you know, in San Jose. So you
know, she thinks she's somebody.
I'm sure that's a fancy thing
to do in San Jose, California.
What a fucking ghost town. That was by
the way. Nobody on the streets. Right.
So, um, yeah, speaking of which, I like,
I actually was going cheap with the fuck
I was going to stay and I actually, uh,
decided to stay at this Ramada,
you know,
thinking that it was, you
know, I'm like, all right,
I tell you 89 bucks for the
night. Fuck it. I'll stay here.
And I'd pull in and it's one of those
deals where the hotel rooms open up,
out into the parking lot. And if
you're a fan of my podcast, you know,
I feel about those. I do not stay,
I don't stay in motels. Okay.
Even if you call it a hotel,
if it fucking opens up,
if your room opens up out into the
parking lot, that's a fucking motel.
Can somebody tell, well, what is the
definition of a motel versa? A hotel.
Because if my world,
if your door opens up to the parking lot,
that is a motel slash this serial killer
buffet where they can just walk down
and be like, I'm going to kill this
guy, I'm going to kill this guy.
Am I fucking with duct guy?
So I never even checked in nor
did I cancel my reservation.
So I wonder, uh, I wonder if
I'm going to pay for that.
I ended up just calling the
Marriott around the corner,
not even worried about whether they had
a fucking room available because I saw
that there was only six
people on the street,
four of which were fucking
crack heads. Um, yeah.
So anyways, so I go to this fucking
game, get back on track here. Yeah.
So this woman, this fur coat, all of a
sudden she gets into it with this guy,
where is this? This, this Red
Wings Jersey and you know,
she's giving him shit.
He's giving it right back to her,
which of course I'm loving.
You know what I mean?
Cause usually the guys back down to women
once they start screaming and public
and he didn't,
he just kept giving a shit right back.
And I don't know what she
said, but she goes, yeah,
you just try me or something like that.
Which was really fucking annoying.
You know, I have a woman act like
they're going to get physical with a man.
Like they going to knock them out.
It's like we do shut up, you know,
I hit you.
I mean I could,
but I'm instantly going to go to fucking
jail and then I'm going to get raped,
you know,
so stop acting like you're fucking tough.
The law is on your side.
All right.
So she's doing all that shit and he's
giving her shit right back and then it's
sort of died down.
Then I started watching the game again
and next thing you know there's just this
commotion and I look
over to my left again.
Now the kid and the Red Wings
Jersey is covered in beer
and he's John at the,
the lady with the fur coat and a,
obviously she dumped it over
his head. You know, I mean,
of course I would too if it was
illegal to kick the shit out of me.
So she dumps it over ahead and he doesn't
blessed her in the face just adding to
her country level that she's
going to be the following day.
The fact that she got away with that and
didn't get dropped. I'm not advocating,
I don't think you should hit a woman,
but I don't feel like women should take
advantage of the fact that a man can't
hit them by just doing over the top
country things like just dumping a beer on
somebody. You know what I mean? So
anyway, so she dumps the beer on the guy,
which I got them in is also
hilarious on another level.
So I didn't hear the exchange, I
guess. I don't know what happens.
All of a sudden this fucking old guy comes
into the picture he's got his face is
all twisted up with angry anger and
he just says to the kid, he goes,
who you calling a bitch?
He must've called the chicken
and for our code a bitch and I,
the kid didn't say anything.
And I swear to God,
this fucking 55 year old dude who was
the slowest punch I've ever seen in my
life, he literally lifted his
hand up like a rock 'em sock.
'Em robot and just through this straight,
not even,
I don't know what the fuck it was.
It was like rock 'em sock 'em he
just see sort of bought them right,
right on the nose. And then the kid
just immediately called for security,
you know, it was just like, wow, that's
really a tough situation. They're like,
he just dealt with two of the
toughest physical confrontations.
A woman dumps a beer over your head,
you want to punch her in the face,
but you can't. But then you allowed
her to dump it over your head.
So he deals with that. Then he has
an old guy punched him in the face.
It's like another man just punched him
in the face. You want to drill them back,
but you can't cause he's an old guy,
but then you will allow to an
old guy to punch you in the face.
So at this point this guy
socially has been raped, right.
So I'm thinking when security
comes down, I'm like, all right,
this guy got punched in the face and a
beer over his head. He might actually,
you know,
he should get out of this even though
he's younger than the two of them and
you're going to be sympathetic
with the old people.
But he immediately screws up cause the
security gets there and he just starts
cursing his brains out going,
I need to do shit.
I was use fucking watching the fucking,
they just snatched him.
They actually smashed all three of them
and 20 minutes later somehow the kid
with the Red Wings Jersey came
back and the two old people didn't.
And I was thinking,
how the fuck did he pull that off?
And the only way I can think of it,
it's as if the old guy admitted
to punching in the face,
which is probably what someone
would do if they weren't a lawyer.
He probably said, well this guy punched
me in the face. And then he probably said,
I did it cause you called my wife a bitch.
And then it became,
do you want to press charges?
And then the old guy gets scared and grabs
his walker and he leaves and then the
fucking Detroit, right when kid
came back, that was my experience.
Was that just a long boring
story that went nowhere.
I kind of lost interest
towards the end of that.
And then mouse started getting
dry. Anyway, this is the month,
the Monday morning podcast and a,
he new to my podcasts.
I do one of these every single week.
And uh,
I think it's becoming really relevant
during these tough economic times,
you know, to just give away
something free like this.
I'm only mentioning that it's free
because somebody told me that they find it
annoying when people say it's
a free podcast, you know,
it's like really well, it is a free
podcast. You fucking douchebag.
And despite the fact that it's free,
people still bitch at me every week,
you know?
So yeah,
I am going to throw it in your
face that I'm doing this for free.
What do you think about that? I'm going
to guilt you. Just like your grandmother,
you know, I saw one of the greatest
movie trailers I've ever seen in my life.
You guys, you guys, fans of the
movie, the dirty dozen. Well,
what is wrong with you? You
should be go, go on Youtube,
hit pause. You don't need to listen to
me right now. This is all you need to do.
If you want to be entertained for free,
just go on youtube and type
in the dirty dozen and watch,
watch the movie trailer of it.
And they have one of the greatest lines
I think that has ever been written.
And they're describing basically
the premise of the movie is this,
these 12 guys who are on basically either
on death row are facing really long
prison sentences.
And if they agree to go on this
suicide mission to kill a bunch of Nazi
officers, if they survive,
they get to go free. And uh,
that's the movie.
So they're basically describing all the
characters and one of the characters
they described as an Indian with
war paint smeared on his soul.
I can't do it justice.
I cannot do it justice.
The guys doing it in that movie voice
and he's not doing it with a hint of how
fucking hilarious it is.
Cause it wasn't the hilarious back then
and Indian was war page smeared and
under his soul. It's just, that's fucking
awesome. I want that as my ringtone. Um,
anyways, so let's get on with the podcast.
Uh, yeah, like maybe new to my podcast.
People send me questions, I answer my
answer the questions the best I can.
People send me their lift of underrated
things they find underrated or overrated
and a movie reviews. Um, and the latest,
the latest is people are
telling me stories of, uh,
of revenge. Um, all right, so
here's one. They're really long.
These people really are writing me like
Stephen King length stories of revenge.
And personally what I've been saying
throughout this is I don't do revenge.
I, uh, I enjoy hearing the stories,
but I don't do it because I just,
my Karma is too fucking strong.
I Dunno man.
Like there's something about
revenge unless it's face to face,
you know, you just sort of
fight somebody, you know,
that seems like an honorable kind
of revenge. But when you sort of,
you start the second year,
like looking at another human being and
they don't know you're looking at them
and you're trying to plan some diabolical
shit. I don't know about you guys,
but there's something inside of me.
I can't fucking do it because I just,
I never feel more evil. I mean,
I'm not going to lie to you.
I've sat around and thought about it,
but to actually carry it out, yeah,
who knows?
Maybe it's exciting.
I never feel more alive than when plotting
the depth of my next door neighbor.
All right, there we go. Um, you know,
that sound byte might to come back to
haunt me in the future when I pull my
Robert Blake in my sixties. Take
that one of the context. All right,
so here's the podcast one.
I'm gonna try to skip through most of
this and just get to the gist of it. Uh,
Bill, I was going to college
in Washington state. Uh,
but I was skipping all of my
classes and getting horrible grades.
The school I was going to was
university of Puget sound,
easily the worst place I've ever
fucking bed to a Yada, Yada, Yada.
So anyways,
there was this kid who was a friend of
mine and at the beginning of the summer,
it was in front of his,
at the beginning of the semester.
But I slowly started to realize
that he was a piece of shit,
which culminated when he also
having red hair fucked my then
girlfriend when she was drunk.
That makes sense.
So basically he had this friend who the
this semester he thought he was cool,
he graduated,
realizes he's a piece of shit.
And the culminated when he fucked his
then girlfriend when she was drunk.
There we go. So anyways, uh,
uh, what he said, he went to this,
this was actually one of the better
moments of my time at the college hearing
that they had hooked up and finding
her the next day. The next morning,
sorry. And she literally
could not look me in the eye,
which in hindsight I find extremely funny.
Um,
and she is shame.
She shamed way explained that
she thought the other guy was me,
but she was so drunk. She
didn't notice. Needless to say,
I was not understanding with her at all.
And maybe out of character choice to
go back to not fucking anyone. Well,
good for you man. That's a strong
choice. Hey, go be alone. Good move.
Um, but this of course then my
friendship with that piece of Shit Kid,
since he confirmed what I
had been suspecting about
him, about big being a, uh,
an asshole. So Blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. This.
So basically the kid stops going to class.
He starts drinking every day and he,
he ends up dropping out.
So, uh, he's cleaning out basically
his room. He goes, so it's my last day.
I'm happy. I'm happier than a crack
head with a hundred dollar bill,
packing my shit up. Then the cock
sucker who fucked my girlfriend,
somehow found me in the hall checking
myself out of my room and he comes up to
me with this incredible shitty shit eating
grin and he says how much he's gonna
miss me and that thickly sarcastic tone.
And then actually proceeded to pinch my
cheek like your grandmother used to when
you were six.
I'm sure you know the feeling of shaking
with rage, being unable to do anything,
being unable to do anything.
Assaulting a kid in a liberal arts school
with security guards right in front of
me would get me arrested.
But of course I still felt like the
world's biggest gaping pussy for not doing
anything at all. Something had to be done
about this. And here comes the revenge,
ladies and gentlemen.
Okay. I decided, said,
I like that kid from the ranch story.
Last week I decided to fuck with his car.
Jesus Christ. Dude. You know,
that's, that's really not,
that's not the man. That's not the, the,
uh, that's not the John Wayne moved there.
You know,
you should have,
you could have always gone back
when the security wasn't there.
And then just started, just fucking
smashed him in the face. I don't know.
So anyways,
he decides to fuck with his car.
Dude, you're reminding
me of that. That uh,
that checked in fast times at Ridgemont
high. That's what, what's what women do?
They write dick or a prick on
the side of your car, whatever.
What am I going to do?
I'm going to stop judging.
I'll just read the rest of the story.
So we had decided to fuck with his car.
He had a nice Jeddah and I knew
where he parked it every night.
So I got a friend to be my lookout as
much as a scumbag as I am for fucking with
someone else's car. All
right, leave the, admitted it.
This could not have gone any
better. Miraculously, there was,
there was this perfect gap in the security
patrols giving me just enough time to
key every panel on his car and slash
all four tires until I was back on the
sidewalk with my friend. Immediately after
finishing a security guard, showed up,
bill old people started doing
their early morning walk to Cetera,
and I got the fuck out of there.
Within an hour,
I caught a bus to Seattle and commerce
started working almost immediately.
Only an hour in front of
my friend's apartment.
An hour later in front of my friend's
apartment, I started feeling awful.
I went from feeling totally fine
to having a, a hallucinatory fever.
Uh, I lay in my friend's bed for
an entire day until around four.
Apparently that jackass discovered what
I did to his car and called my phone
over and over from a
number from his number,
then from all my friends' phones,
et Cetera.
I don't remember much
of this conversation,
but I do know I was trying
to be a tough guy. Uh,
blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. So the kid kept calling
for months and months. Eventually I
stopped answering his calls, but he,
he kept calling, dude,
you fucked with a psycho.
You know, when he came up and pinched
your cheek like that, and it said,
how much did you do?
Realize how,
what a sadistic fucking
maniac you would dealing with.
It's probably good you didn't fucking
punch him cause he probably would've came
at you like Hannibal Lecter and fitting
the Chunky a cheek right out of your
face.
But anyways,
he said he even called me on Christmas
almost a month later when he would call
it these times
always on available blah blah blah.
Oh this is a good party.
I'd answer.
And he'd start making heavy
breathing noises after awhile.
Like those telephone perverts
women were afraid of in the 1960s
a story has a happy ending though.
Uh, at one of those hipsters bar,
a sort of gothic coffee shop.
Actually I managed to hook up with a girl
that was probably out of my league by
playing off his constant cycle of phone
calls as though there were other chicks
trying to get with me.
I Dunno when it does that.
It sounds like the number one thing.
Well it's like with revenge. I'm sorry,
like that was really choppy,
but I swear to God the kid
wrote me like a manifesto.
I was really trying and I don't have time
to edit these fucking things, but uh,
that seems to be people's
number one a way of
taking revenge on somebody.
You know,
you got to get out there and uh,
fuck with their car.
I guess that what's makes it Ben,
right? Revenge has to be sneaky.
She, wait a minute, we've got
two guys fucking with a car.
Then we had another guy who took
his girlfriend to Disneyland,
his ex girlfriend who cheated on him.
It did horrific things to her.
You know what he's about revenge.
It has to be sneaky.
Cause even that chick thought she was
going to Disneyland to ride on the tea
cups and to get back with this guy and
he was actually taking her down there to,
to make a porno. Uh, do you know something
that's, that's what it is about revenge.
I can't deal with,
I can't deal with the dishonesty of it.
There's just something that just makes
you feel like you just feel dirty.
You know
the fuck up somebody's car.
You should do it right in front
of them as you look at them.
With some of maniacal look on your face.
I mean that would really,
you know when that get them,
cause then you'd be like, wow,
this guy knows I fucked him
up if he fucked with my car
and not only is he doing
in front of me, he made sure he called
out my name. So I saw him doing it.
You know what I mean?
Got It.
You know their minds,
me on what time?
I saw this crazy white dude on the subway
and he was rapping some song and that
had the n word in it and there was like
10 black people on the train. Okay.
And he's dropping the n
bomb every five seconds.
I'm a pretty easy Edward Sam,
something,
some crazy and we're doing the
best of can and then he go, right.
Woo.
You just kept doing it over and over
out of his fucking mind.
But why is health all
the downtown's checks?
Back in the day when I lived
on the upper east side,
he kept saying it over and over again.
It was like, you know, it was a subway.
It was like 10 15 black dudes on
the train who was a white dude.
He's dropping the Edward. Every white
person knows if you fucking do that,
if it's instantaneous ass kicking.
But I think that that's what saved him.
It's because he was so overtly doing it.
All the black people looked at him.
We're like,
this guy knows we're going to kick the
fuck out of him yet he's still doing it.
So then you just do the quick math.
Oh he's fucking crazy.
He's crazy.
Okay,
I'm going to fight this guy and he's
going to bite me and I'm going to get
hepatitis. So that's the, uh,
I know what the fuck point I'm trying
to make that that's how you get out of,
I guess got nugget and your advocate.
Cause if you can truly convince
people that you're fucking crazy,
like people just, they don't,
they don't mess with you.
So that's what you should have done.
They didn't,
you want to cheat his
fucking car in front of them.
They just have a maniacal look at
your face. And every other sentence,
just scream out,
ooh.
And
they leave you alone. Then you have
to dealt, dealt with the phone calls.
Then again, you wouldn't have hooked
up with the chicken, the coffee shop.
I don't know. Let's get to the podcast
questions. Shall We? I get a phone.
I get fucking, I get a cold here. Okay.
I'll make an excuse as to that last two
minutes. That didn't even make sense.
All right, podcast
question number one. Well,
he talked about wanting to have a kid now,
now that you're getting older,
I'm just curious to know if you would
want him or her to hear your podcasts.
Considering you condone
things like revenge.
I love how people don't listen to me.
I don't condone revenge.
I've said that on every podcast,
but I do find the is interesting and I
will comment and laughed at the shift
that you did.
I don't condone what Scarface did,
but I can enjoy him shooting up people
in the end of the movie, you know?
Anyway, so he, but anyways, the way this
guy heard it maybe have maybe, you know,
maybe I wasn't clear about
what I was saying. So anyways,
the way he heard it is basically I
couldn't, don't things like prevention.
He said,
I he busting a nut on your x face to make
her feel like a whore for cheating on
you.
I'm not criticizing you.
I'm sincerely interested in knowing
if having a child will change your
perception on things because
as I closed it on 40,
I'm feeling the same way,
wanting to finally have a kid and it
makes me consider if I should adjust my
moral compass beforehand because I would
want my son or daughter to have me as a
decent role model. Your situation is a
little more precarious in the your future.
10 year old son could find an old
copy of bill burrs greatest hits.
And here I was,
father thinks that come and a girl's
hair is the best prescription for
heartbreak. Keep up the good work. Ah,
all right Michael, this is how
I view this type of shit. Um,
for me to actually think about anything
that I'm saying on this podcast about
actually having a child that I don't
even have is the quickest way of making
these podcasts horrifically. Unfunny. Um,
um,
I actually,
I have major problems with parents
and how once they have kids,
they all of a sudden start acting like
they're not the fucking frat boy date
rape is that they used to be.
And not only do they act that way,
they want everyone else
to behave that way too,
because they knocked up the check
that they're with and it's like, dude,
I didn't knock up my curl. Okay. I'm
still having a good fucking time.
You know what I mean? So if
my, you know what, why don't,
why don't I do the rest of this
spot, this, this moment right now,
like my future 10 year old son is actually
listening to the archives. Hey son,
what's going on?
It's your dad.
I hope I didn't fuck up the first
10 years of your life. Listen son,
if you're taking anything that I say
on these podcasts remotely, seriously,
I've completely failed as a parent and
I want you to go outside and fall on a
fucking lawn dark cause I'm going to start
over again and I'm gonna make another
kid and uh, I'm going to teach them
to learn how to fucking take a joke.
I don't know.
You know what?
I got halfway through that
and just got fucking creepy.
I just told him my future kid to kill
himself with a toy that has been banned.
Um, no, to be honest with
you, you know, I never,
I never think about what you're asking me.
Do I swear to God?
Is the formula for not becoming funny?
You know,
that's what comedians
do is they get older,
they have kids and all of a sudden they
stopped cursing on stage and they stay,
want to be a role model and uh,
that's when shit just starts
going down hill and you know,
you want to start doing family movies,
you know,
and I'm not doing that.
Okay. I'm a comedian.
Nothing I say should be taken seriously.
And if you take it seriously,
that's not my problem.
Even if you are on my kid,
I'm be honest with my kid.
You know what I mean?
Don't people like trying to shelter their
kid and tell him that there's a Santa
clause and everything like that.
And you know, I dunno about that.
Like if somebody does something really
weird and then my kids like why did
somebody, why did that person do
that? I'd be like, you know what son?
Cause most people are, you know, I
know it's a harsh reality and uh,
enjoy your coloring years sun
cause it's only going to get worse.
I'm going to get worse. All
right. Uh, listening to,
uh, okay. Bill listening to
be newly discovered podcast.
You, Oh, this is the guy. You
know what, this guy, I'm going to,
I'm going to say this guy for this,
this right here. Not as whole email,
but this email right here, I think
this guy earns Douche bag of the, uh,
of the fucking week because he goes,
you should charge for your podcast and
up the production value or just leave
them as they are.
Just don't keep mentioning that they're
free like other podcasts is due.
It's a bit Douchey when you do that.
You know what?
Why don't you go fuck yourself? How
about you do that? Does that Douchey?
If I tell you that you fucking cunt,
they'll tell me what to do in
this fucking podcast is free.
I don't need to do this.
Shift going to tell me how the fuck
I'm supposed to do these. All right?
So go fuck yourself on your
first paragraph. But because
I'm such a sweetheart,
I'll read the rest of it. The
rest of it. You don't bug me.
You're a Douche in your
first paragraph. Uh, Bill.
So with the video call you to come and
I kind of assume you are a drummer like
me and with the headphone comment
drummer headphones gotta be right.
Uh Oh gotta be right. So if you are a
drummer and listen through headphones,
listen to Steve, Steve, oh seven days.
Then in parentheses it says, uh,
staying field of gold though they did,
they did a cover of that.
Yeah.
I don't know if you guys will
listen to the podcasts, but that's,
I'm kind of into,
I've been starting to buy records,
started buying them again and find like
some concept albums and that's, you know,
those all those great old albums.
So just great. Somebody sent,
somebody wrote something on the
Internet where they would just,
they were bitching about music today
and they said something to the effect of
how,
you know,
how bummed they worked because people
today don't want to hear good music.
I just think that's such a hilarious
comments. People today. Yeah.
They don't want to hear good music. Oh
yeah, that's, that's exactly what it is.
It has nothing to do with the deregulation
of media in the early 1980s which
allowed fucking five guys to buy all
the fucking radio stations and to run
everyone exactly like the other one.
Thus limiting the amount of
music that can get on the radio.
That's not what it is. It's that people
then they don't want to hear the music.
Is that good music? You shut that
off, Mr. I don't want to hear that.
I want to hear some awful, I don't
want to hear good music. You know,
it's funny,
there's the cleaning ladies on the
outside of the door and she thinks I can't
hear. And I know she's
listening to me ranting it here,
debating whether or not to come in
here enough. I know you're out there.
Um,
don't just freaked around.
And it kind of freaked me out too,
cause I realized that technically I
really am not talking to anybody. Um,
what was I talking about?
Oh yeah, the music.
I think there's plenty of good
music out there. You just hit,
you get assessed to find it.
It's on the Internet now and
possibly on satellite radio.
And if you don't have satellite radio,
that's one of the most
underrated things ever. Uh,
it's fucking incredible. And I'm, I'm
getting there putting my car because,
uh, I've rented a few cars recently and
they had satellite ready radio in it and
that's where the good music is.
That's where the funny radio shows are.
That's where it's at when it comes to
radio. Man, it's fucking great. And, uh,
and people curse on the radio,
which I enjoy.
And if I had a 10 year old son,
I let I let them listen to those words
because I always heard him from the day I
was walking around.
I heard them and look at me.
I turned out fine and I
did two stop laughing.
I did pay my fucking taxes. I'm
not hurting anybody. I'm anyways.
Overrated. Underrated, uh, overrated.
This guy says sonic youth
dot, dot, dot. Really?
You know what?
I don't know.
Why are they the ones who are saying
a runaway train about the kids who run
away?
Run away.
[inaudible] code back fillet
something Yak. A Paul Simon. Dot Dot. Dot.
I want to shove an African drum
up his ass. Is he black now?
Okay. Listened to any Paul Simon album
in the late eighties, early nineties.
Do you ever think he was just trying to
spend as an artist and he was working
with different musicians and the
went outside of America? You know,
it's not like he went out there with
the Fubu fucking track suit on when he
played with them. Notice I said, Fubu,
staying in size with the early nineties
was Booboo, wasn't it? It was at midnight.
You know, Jesus Christ. Who did he black.
Now he's standing next to a black guy.
He's still wearing those wrangler jeans.
It was awful. Hair plugs, uh,
BB King and the other
guy says is overrated.
He's been milking the legend
status for so long. He can't eat.
He can't even play a chord.
C You two's rattle and hum dude,
I got to agree with you on
that one. Bb King, I think.
Uh, yeah, I think he might be a little
overrated. The guy can't play a chord.
A, he does play nicely,
but if you've noticed,
there's not a lot of black
people going up to see him.
I think it's a bunch of white
people who think he's good.
That was one of the most ignorant fucking
things all over say a that really made
me laugh. You know, and that guy who
sent me the email, I didn't mean that.
So in the future where my 10 year
old son hears it, I, you know,
he's going to know Jesus Christ.
Why would you put that in my fucking head?
I never think shit like that.
That's how you know,
if you think about ramifications,
you're never going to be funny. Hey,
what if I say this?
Won't that hurt someone in the crowd?
And then the moment to set it is gone
and it's over five bad shows tonight.
I'm going to fucking blame
you. Hey, like that. Alright.
Underrated the May field four miles.
Kennedy.
I have no idea who that is. I'm going
to look that up. And Roy Orbison,
he's one of those guys who was overrated.
Underrated.
I think he's underrated with the
average listener. And he's overrated.
When you just talk about
him, about his, uh,
seven octave voice and he,
I dunno,
he really has an amazing
range with his voice,
but I don't like the sound of it.
Is that like sac religious?
What are some of the songs he thinks?
Pretty woman.
Ooh.
Kill yourself. He goes like a
lesbian. All right. Underrated. Uh,
the lightness of college chicks.
Um,
I don't care. I'll figure the Roy
Orbison, he died out of nowhere, man.
Like I just had a heart attack.
That's what I, those guys,
when he dies of a heart attack, you really
look at his face and it's like, yeah,
I can see the heart attack. He
had blue cheese, double chin,
underrated.
The sluttiness of college chicks.
I don't care where you went to college,
if you lived,
if you lived away at school and
weren't getting laid once a week,
something must be wrong with your Dick.
This is over exaggerating a bit.
That's one of my favorite expressions.
I think I've ever read over exaggerating.
I'm trying to do the math on what
the fuck that means. So if you said,
if you lived away at school and we're
getting laid at least once a week,
if you weren't getting
laid at least once a week,
something must be wrong with your Dick.
But that statement is, is over exaggerated
over it.
So does that mean you're not exaggerating?
Does that mean to get laid one and a
half times a week and tag someone finger?
Bless someone else? I really
don't do sex jokes. I really that,
that makes me uncomfortable. Uh, but this
is over exaggerating a bit, but I still,
it is ridiculous.
I went to a small Catholic college,
but you would know about the stories I
got from my dorm room. A couple bears,
some can't even read this.
Do you guys even guys like against using
the space bar? A couple of beers, some
dim dorm room lighting and slow jams
playlist off your laptop and you were in
business most of the time. It didn't
even matter if your roommates were there.
I want to have my roommate wake up to
this bitch sitting on my face riding a
unicycle. All right, we're going to
stop there. Okay, I got it. Dude.
You're getting laid.
Jesus Christ.
You know what? That's actually
true. I never lived at college,
but I definitely hooked up with college
girls and I actually hooked up with the
girl in the top bunk and
they're in a roommate.
Not only was in the
bottom bunk but was awake.
You haven't tried to fuck respectively
versus the respective kind of way.
It doesn't really work.
Uh,
especially when you use a word you
can't even pronounce respectively.
Does that even does that even
a word. All right. Overrated.
Adding why to the end of guys' names,
unless you're playing stick ball in the
school yard or your grandma calls to
wish you a happy birthday.
If you're over the age of 18 year old
man and should not be referred to as Joey
or daddy or any other bullshit name ending
and why I'm hoping you would want to
punch. The first guy walks up and says,
hey Billy, what's up? It's bullshit.
You're a man. Should go buy a man's name.
You know what? That's exactly right.
I actually,
when I first game game into this business,
I went by Bill Burr and I thought it was
too short and too difficult to say so
for like five years I went by Billy bur.
Then even though it flowed
better with my last name,
anytime anybody called me that it just,
it didn't feel right.
It was just like a,
unless the guy was some like New Jersey,
they have a way of making it sound all
right in New York guys. But it's just,
I just felt like a little kid,
like I should have been sitting there
with my brown sack lunch and after,
I don't know how Billy crystal does it,
so I would have to agree with
you on that one. All right.
I think that's it. I think
that's it for the podcast. Uh,
I want to thank everyone
for listening this week.
It's a little bit on the short side,
but, um, I don't know. It's weird.
I'm up in San Francisco and I got a gig
tonight and before I even do the Gig,
I want to thank everybody for coming
out on a Monday night. I know. It's, uh,
you know, it's a work night for you guys,
you working hard and that type of shit.
So, uh, listen to this
before we come up to my show,
I'm going to try out this new chunk and
I'm probably going to bomb, but, uh,
definitely going to give
you your money's worth.
I really appreciate
everybody who showed up
or who's gonna show up or if this
is the next day who has showed up?
Jesus Christ. They'll get to the point
and a next week I'm going to be in the,
not this upcoming weekend, the following
weekend, last weekend in March,
I'm going to be at the uh,
uh,
the house of comedy in East Saint Louis.
All the information's on a
billboard.com and anything else?
Oh, and I'm going to be on
the opie and Anthony Show. Um,
when I got, I got to Atlantic city
date covenant. What is the fucking day?
Hold on one second. I got to
figure this out. I need a calendar.
God dammit.
Hang on a second.
He knows podcast cancer's going
pretty smooth up until this point.
This is just garbage time. You can hang
up right now. You don't listen to this.
All right. It's the Trump marina
gig is on April 4th. All right,
so that's the Saturday.
So Friday the third,
second first, the first, second and
third at least. I'm going to be going,
I'm going to be on the
opiate Anthony show.
I'm going back into New York and I'm
going to visit my, my good friends,
um, opie and Anthony and, uh,
they always hilarious little Jimmy Norton.
And I'm really excited to get back there.
Um,
it's been number one thing that
I miss about living in New York.
I fucking love doing that show. And, um,
it is on XM satellite radio because
satellite radio was the shit XM two o two.
And, uh, we'll be doing the taping,
an uninformed episode
with Joe de Rosa and,
uh, and that is it. I think that's it.
I'll also be at the lake shore, could, uh,
theater in Chicago,
Illinois on a April 3rd look at me,
zig zag and across the fucking country.
Alright. Right. And that is it.
You guys all have yourself a good week
and God bless the United States of
America saying
no to the marrow and the North
American Union and microchip.
Oh,
wow.
That,
I don't know.
[inaudible].